[Music]
this is the closet of my dreams and I
just get to take whatever I want
borrow is that an actual rule okay so
you want to start with a protective base
layer I recommend the pita tummy sole
yeah some kind of polymer material
bulletproof composite for Yama it was
originally developed as a protective
layer for spacecraft
yeah and it's a brother doesn't dig
progress how we doing down here
ah we're still in the first closet
there's another closet armory open
[Music]
hello
you're in great danger get out of there
now open safe house six
welcome to the Townsend agency I run a
covert group of exceptional women
you guys are like lady spies we work
outside the rules like that in secret
together
you may not know we exist but we are
always watching you are in the presence
of angels so you want to train to be an
angel hell yeah give me my wings
[Music]
sit down and keep your hands where I can
see them really not supposed to be
touching things in here unless you're
supposed to be touching things I mean
you're adorable J is that you flirting
with a handsome
[Music]
the best part is them taking down
international criminals
with you guys
in the day drinking that's what I like
the most
[Music]
so I can just take whatever I want Baro
is that an actual rule
hey time to go to work
[Music]